actually the saddest news story I've
read over the weekend there were a
number of sad ones
adults
are now
for their Recreation going to bouncy
castles
I saw this story
in in the Wall Street Journal Wall
Street Journal is not a sensationalist
tabloid paper far from it very stable
stayed establishment paper
the new Night Out adults only bouncy
houses
grown-ups try to rekindle a childhood
Pastime this time with Achy muscles that
hurt my back
adults are discovering that jumping in
bouncy houses a childhood Pastime is not
the same when you're older and less
nimble
grown-ups aren't just hopping with their
kids but are increasingly bouncing
around with other full-grown humans
adults are renting bouncy houses for
weddings birthdays and Company parties
some are having as much fun as
youngsters occasionally helped by
pre-bounce booze adults don't bounce
back the way they used to and then it
talks about how they you know their
backs hurt or something afterwards
this is just the latest iteration of a
trend that we saw through McDonald's
where McDonald's was was going to sell
happy meals for adults kids meals that
were not for kids that are for adults
the trend of adults
going regularly without kids to
Children's theme parks
that why are adults doing this
adults are doing this
because they don't have kids
there are some right-wingers and
conservatives who are just going to make
fun of these adults say these adults are
losers they're they they're never grew
up they're overgrown children this is
pathetic they're going to mock them for
wanting to do these things that's not my
take on it actually
my take is that these adults have
perfectly normal nostalgia
perfectly normal desires to have fun
there are there are other ways to have
fun than just like going to a bar or
something like that so I recognize their
other being a kid is kind of fun and
adults remember that
but this is the wrong way to follow
those desires and that inclination
the right way to follow those Desires in
that inclination is to have kids
this one of the secret little joys of
having kids is you get to do kid things
again and kid things are fun
it's fun to go throw a ball around in a
park it's fun to like wrestle on the
floor and play with cars and stuff it's
fun to go ride bikes around the
neighborhood it's fun to go to bouncy
castles and eat Happy Meals and that is
a fun thing to do
but it's
weird if you do it without kids not
everyone gets to have kids some people
suffer infertility you can do it with
your nieces and nephews you can do it in
your community and go kind of rough ass
with the kids okay yeah that's kind of
that isn't that fun but if you do it
as an adult
you it's sad
because you
you haven't grown up right now text
Knowles to 98 98 98 Congress once again
has allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for these 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar as our national debt continues to
Skyrocket how are you protecting your
savings Times Like These are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold and you can do that
with the help of Birch gold these are
the guys I trust to get your gold from
thousands of other concerned Savers do
as well Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't have to pay a penny out
of pocket and you can be like me
have your Birch gold ready to go when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text null skin wlas to
98 98.98 get your free info kit on gold
text Knowles to 98 98.98 right now go to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles it's
our great Nations birthday approaches we
are coming together as proud Americans
and savoring the delicious Taste of
home-grown American-made meat our
friends at good Ranchers have the best
Quality Meats you've ever tasted and
they only sell meat that was raised here
in the U.S of a from now until
Independence Day good ranchers will be
offering the best deals to give you
freedom from the meat aisle from rib
eyes New York strips all natural Burgers
to the most delicious chicken you could
ever want good ranchers has something
for everyone plus right now you will get
30 bucks off with code Knowles kwles
goodranchers.com if you are looking for
a way to wow your family during your
fourth of July Gathering check out their
website recipe of the Texas style
chopped patty melt it is so freaking
good they have the best meat on the
market the prices are lower than
everybody's they're just phenomenal okay
what are you waiting for let the aroma
of American made meat fill the air
we enjoy unity and delectable flavors to
your celebrations goodranches.com use
code Knowles for 30 bucks off any box
Canada w-les that's the code
goodranches.com goodranchers.com
American Meat delivered
it's just you can't you actually can't
go back in time this is the whole
premise I've said it before on this show
this is the premise of that Kenny loggin
the song
the back and Pooh Corner to help me if
you can I've got to get back it's this
whole song about how this kid is
graduating high school and he's out in
the 100 Acre Wood with Winnie the Pooh
but he can't he can't get back he
doesn't
he wants to go get back and hang out
with his friends uh Eeyore and Winnie
the Pooh and
I don't really remember the Winnie the
Pooh story that much because because I'm
an adult but
he wants to go back and he realizes he
can't because he's become an adult and
that is now closed off to him but the
final verse of the song
is that he looks into his son's crib and
he sees that his son has a little Winnie
the Pooh doll or a Tigger doll or
something like that and he says oh I I'm
I'm back now I get to go back to Pooh
Corner now but it's through this
different lens in a different place and
now I am in a new stage of life and I'm
passing this on to the next Generation
but we don't have a sense of the future
in our country anymore we don't have
hope for the future we don't have a
sense of responsibility toward the
future that's why we don't really get
married we don't really have kids and
The Inheritance that we leave to the
kids that we do have is a mountain of
debt
that is a political problem not just
from the libs
who are the drivers of a lot of the
sexual dysfunction but that's a problem
for the conservatives who are who are
the drivers of some of the economic
dysfunction and the the
economic dysfunction that's led to a
breakdown in Social solidarity and an
idea that we have a great responsibility
both to our ancestors and to the Future
that comes after us all encapsulated in
a big bouncy house that a lot of
overgrown children are are hopping
around in and they're hurting their
backs they're hurting their backs
because they're not meant to be there
meant to be helping the Next Generation
and getting to relive some of their
memories a little bit
in conjunction with them boy wasn't that
a great clip
here on YouTube It Was Here on YouTube
isn't that great make sure you subscribe
to the Michael Knowles Show YouTube
channel well you still can and we'll see
you next time